[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I got held up at work
you'll be working this weekend well it
can't be helped
father I never see your life is
happening now right in front of you
I am sorry Madeline
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do what to
do and become
[Music]
Oh Christopher Robin fear oh no no no no
no this can't be happening
stress it's not stress its pooh pooh how
are you here oh well I went through the
door through which Christopher Robin is
known to appear and now I'm here the
tree I remember we find the causes in
the countryside not here in London I
suppose it's where it needs to be that's
a silly explanation wash thank you
I've lost all of my friends we need to
find them although there are you on an
expedition Oh bother
hmm do you think he's alright come here
come in here okay can't just keep saying
hello to people people can't see moving
and talking but why because you're
different so I shouldn't be me no no no
sword for yourself no this is very
confusing just try and be LLS a less
exuberant to you looks too boring flop
sag play nap time I love play well let's
see it like this well done
do you think you might be able to amuse
yourself for a while I've got some
bother pressing what to do house clouds
tree
doll Oh what are you doing oh I'm
playing a game it's called
say what you see look could you say what
you see a little more quietly
[Music]
house grass trees I'm sorry the snack
apartment
it's rather full that's his nap time
[Music]
Christopher Robin you're back exactly
the pace giant oh and he smells a little
funny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just an average Wednesday morning not
who I used to be and lost you need to
remember who you are
Kristopher always comes to save us no
it's our turn to save him
let's bounce
it's always a sunny day
when Christopher Robin comes to play a
little better Disney's Christopher Robin
what's called say what you'll see if I
steal your disgrace - a little
humiliation well that's one way to play
it
in theaters August 3rd rated PG get
tickets now what should happen if you
forget about me silly old fair
oh never forget about you pay a promise
even when I'm a hundred we should be
working this weekend Robin but I
promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you won't be coming to the cottage well
it can't be helped your life is
happening now right in front of you what
to do what to do what to do what to do
indeed poor Christopher Robin hello
the tree I remember was in the
countryside not here in London this is
our opening
I suppose it's where it needs to be
that's a silly explanation watch thank
you
oh why are you here oh yes I need your
help
I've lost all of my friends let's get to
the bottom of this look up here I come
oh it would appear that I am stuck have
you just eaten honey I have not just
anything daddy
I wonder which way I always get to where
I'm going by walking away from where I
have been no you that's the way I go
atern hello your Christopher Robin it's
you played its gonna see if i thinkit's
I've already stayed far too long so nice
to see you all again
why shake you silly old bear I was wrong
about work I was wrong about everything
and I've got to get back to my family
farewell Christopher Robin I would have
liked it to go on for a while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
[Music]
you must be Madeleine wait he'll the
bear of my father's drawings
yes do you know where he is I did you
saw the most preposterous him
[Music]
if anyone wants to clap now is the time
to do it I don't remember being cheery
people say nothing is impossible but I
do nothing every day
you know prove that's not
you
[Music]